Okay, so we're going to go over to Chris
again now, and Chris is going to show you
how to calculate your own expected or
implied volatility index. So you can do
this for multiple assets as long as you
can get the options data. So let's go over
to Chris, and Chris is going to show you
how to do that now.
In this video, I'm going to take you
through an example of how you can
calculate your own implied volatilities
for any given asset. So the reason why
looking at implied volatilities is useful
is because it's our only four
looking volatility indicator. And by that
I mean it doesn't rely on historical price
data like calculating a distribution of
returns does or an average shoe range. So
the way it works is we use a theoretical
option pricing formula to back out implied
volatilities from observed option prices
in the market. Now before we get started,
I'll make a quick note on the spreadsheet
that accompanies this video. It's set up
so that you can only calculate implied
volatilities from call options on
underlying assets that don't pay dividends
within the lifetime of the option.
So in this example, we're going to look at
options on the S&P 500 to infer forward
looking volatility for the S&P 500. So
let's get started by opening up the
implied vol spreadsheet.
So once you open the spreadsheet it should
look something like this. Now on the left
hand side we have data inputs and these
are the cells that we're going to be
putting data into which the ones that are
highlighted in light blue are the only
ones we should need to edit on this
spreadsheet. All the other cells are
automated.
So when we enter these inputs and an
observed option price on the market we'll
end up with an observed option price and a
theoretical option price and what we do is
we minimize the difference between the
observed price and the theoretical price
by changing the theoretical price towards
the observed price.
And we do that by changing the implied
volatility in this cell. So the way we get
our data inputs is through the resources
section of the spreadsheet and we're
looking at the S&P 500 in this example. So
the resources section is set up to be able
to find US data fairly easily.
When you come to do your own implied
volatility calculations you might want to
add to this resource section using
different countries websites. So let's get
started by opening the CBOE website and
finding options on the S&P 500.
So if we just click on the CBOE link in
the resources section of the spreadsheet
and we go to quotes and data hover over
that and left click on delayed quotes
classic. We can use just standard delayed
quotes but sometimes it's a bit
temperamental so we're going to use
delayed quotes classic in this example.
And we put SPX into the ticker box down
here and click submit so SPX is the ticker
for the S&P 500 on the CBOE website.
And the first thing we're going to note is
that the spot price of the underlying
asset the S&P 500 is displayed at the top
right of this options data table.
So that's 1574.57 and that's one of the
inputs that we need for our spreadsheet so
we'll go ahead and put that in now.
So 1574.57
Yep.
And next I'll explain how this table is
set out.
So we're only looking at call options
remember so we're looking at the left hand
side of this website of this web page and
the columns so the calls column under the
calls column we've got the contract names
of all the option contracts.
So we have the last sale which is the
price of the option the last sale price
and we've got volume and open interest
columns which are indicators of liquidity
and when we look at options and backing
out implied volatilities from options we
want to use a liquid contract because the
price is more reliable.
So as I'm doing this it's the 16th of
April so I'm going to be looking at
options in May with an expiry in May so I
use this middle column to scroll down to
May and as well as the date so 13th of May
here it's got the strike price in the
middle column as well.
So we go to a May contract we're going to
go find a contract that's got decent
liquidity and has a strike price that is
near the money so that means a strike
price listed in the middle column that is
close to the spot price of the underlying
asset so the S&P 500.
So we go down and we're going to find a
May call option with a strike price of
$1,570 so we go down to May $1,570 so this
one and it's got decent liquidity so we
click on the contract name on the left
hand side and open this up and it gives us
a few more details about this contract.
So let's go ahead and put the next piece
of data into our spreadsheet which is the
strike price of the option we're looking
at which is $1,570.
So put in $1,570 into the next cell and
the next input we'll put in is the expiry
date of the option which is on this page
that we've just navigated to and that is
the 3rd of May 2013 as you can see this
dates in American format.
Now my spreadsheet at the moment is set up
in the UK date format which will be the
default format that you're supplied with.
So I'll input this as 3rd of May 2013 and
you can see this has automated the number
of days from today until that date and
automated the time to maturity in years
that that represents which is then put
into the theoretical option price.
So before we continue let's point out you
need to change the format of this cell of
H5 the date cell to match the date format
of your system clock.
So if you're using American date format on
your system you need to change the date
format of this cell to American format.
And if you don't the automation of the
spreadsheet won't work so to change the
format we right click on the cell go to
format cells and then change the location
here and press ok.
I'm going to press cancel because mine's
already set up as the UK format.
So the last piece of data that we get from
the CBOE website is the observed option
price.
So the observed option price was 18.93
we're going to use the last sale.
So 18.93.
So we put in 18.93 into cell E10.
Now the last piece of data the last input
we need to calculate our theoretical
option price is the risk free interest
rate.
So because we're looking at the S&P 500
we're going to use US Treasury to find a
risk free rate and we'll use a short term
bond.
So if we click on this link for the risk
free rate go to the US Treasury website
and we find a one month yield starting in
April.
So 0.07%.
So we enter 0.07%.
This cell's already set up to display
itself in percentage so we just put in
0.07%.
And that's our last piece of data.
Now you can see that the theoretical
option price differs from the observed
option price.
And that's because we're using an implied
volatility or volatility of 0.1 which was
the default for the spreadsheet when it
opened.
And what we're going to do is change this
cell, change the theoretical option price
by changing the volatility so that we can
match the observed option price.
And we do that by minimizing this cell
which is just the difference between those
two.
So let's go ahead and do that.
So if we navigate to data and then solver
on the right hand side.
Now if you don't already have solver
installed as a plugin, there's a guide of
how you can do that in the accompanying
PDF.
So you can go through that, install solver
and then follow on from here.
So let's click on solver.
And if you already have solver installed,
it should come up with the parameters
already built in.
So you don't need to press anything, you
just click solve and it will work.
If not, you'll need to input these cells.
So we'll go through it anyway.
So what we're doing is we're setting the
objective which is cell F17 which is the
difference between the theoretical and
observed option price.
And we're trying to minimize that by
changing the cell F20 which is the
volatility.
So you can set up that yourself quite
easily.
And then we're going to click solve.
And this is telling us, solver results is
telling us that it's converged to a
solution.
So it's found an implied volatility.
Occasionally, solver can be a bit
temperamental.
If it doesn't find a solution and you
haven't made any other mistakes in the
spreadsheet, have a go at just changing
the volatility cell yourself.
So this is the only time you should change
a cell that isn't highlighted in light
blue.
So have a go at changing this volatility
cell yourself so that this theoretical
pricing cell just starts to move towards
the market price.
And then give solver another go and
usually it works a second time around.
So we just press ok.
So this has given us a volatility of 0.12.
Now what this cell represents is a measure
of annualized volatility that's been
calculated from an option price that we've
observed in the market that's forward
looking by 17 days.
And it's scaled it up to annualized the
implied volatility within that option.
And so the first thing we can do is
compare this to the VIX because the VIX
gives us a gauge and understanding of the
volatility of the S&P 500.
So if we go to VIX and say the VIX
volatility on the S&P 500.
So this is sitting at 13.96 which is
fairly close to our 12.2.
So if you just times this figure by 100
then that's what it should give.
So 12.2 against 13.6 to get it in terms of
a percentage.
So the reason there's a little bit of a
discrepancy there is just the way we've
calculated it compared to the way the VIX
has calculated it.
So we've just used one option price and
worked out the implied volatility given
that option price.
The VIX uses a more complicated method
where it averages many different implied
volatilities given from a ton of different
options with different strike prices.
And also uses a nearer term and a longer
term option expiry date.
And if you want to know a little bit more
about why this might be lower.
Generally this will be lower than the VIX.
That's because of something called the
volatility smile which is mentioned in the
accompanying PDF.
And basically it shows that the implied
volatility is calculated from options with
strike prices that are near the money.
Are generally lower than those further
from the money.
So when you've got the VIX which is
calculated using an average of lots of
different strike prices.
It's going to be higher generally.
Not by much but a little bit.
Than our implied volatility of an option
on the S&P 500 that's near the money.
So let's think about how we're going to
interpret this a little bit more.
We know about standard deviation.
So let's change this to a forward looking,
a monthly forward looking standard
deviation.
So in cell F23 we'll use.
We type equals F20 which is our implied
volatility.
Divided by square root.
So SQRT brackets 12.
So that will give us a monthly standard
deviation.
Calculated from an annualized volatility.
And it's monthly because it's using the
square root of 12.
So that's 12 months in a year.
So we're finding a monthly standard
deviation.
So if you want to find a 2 month standard
deviation you just use 6 in these brackets
here.
So we go ahead and press enter.
And we'll just format this cell to display
itself in terms of a percentage.
Okay.
So this is showing a standard deviation of
3.52% for forward looking by a month.
So what that means is if returns are
normally distributed.
Which is what we consider or what we look
at when we look at the returns
distribution of assets.
If they're normally distributed we can say
that 68% of the time within the next
month.
So we would expect the underlying assets
of the S&P 500 to move by 3.5% up or down
from the mean movement that it's had
historically.
And as well if you know how a normal
distribution works we can scale that up.
So 95% of the time there's a 95%
probability that the S&P will move within
2 times the standard deviation up and down
within the next month.
So that's how we interpret this figure
here.
So you may want to go back to the returns
distribution video and re-look at how
normal distributions work.
And remind yourself of returns
distributions in general.
And basically what this is allowing us to
do is to realize our forward looking
opportunities to trade the market.
So as implied volatility goes up we can
look to make profit from shorter term
trades.
And as it goes down we move more into a
portfolio management stance and look at
longer term time horizons.